okay guys so it's kind of hot out
steamy whatever
um but I was thinking
and I was thinking about how a lot of
times when red pill will talk about
women they'll stay there
red pillars YouTubers whatever they'll
say like modern women are
modern women are fat on birth control
sleep route whatever it is
why then the the other guys will say
well you guys are all just doomsdayers
you all just are big
doomsdayers or whatever
and I've like kind of stepped back to
just like think about this I'm like
why is it the men's fault
for talking about the reputation that we
made
you know if you have someone that let's
let's bring it to an individual level if
you have a person in a town and that
person robs everyone or
that person
sleeps with everyone doesn't call them
back whatever if it's a guy
you don't blame everyone else for
talking about his reputation but for
some reason with women
if they build up if we as a group build
up a reputation the men are the bad guys
for talking about it for making a
generalization and my thing is
um
well is it true or is it not true and I
think that has to be like the first
response that we as women have
um because a lot of times we'll kind of
go to personal attacks or we'll go to
well not all women are like that or
whatever but I think the first response
has to be is it true
and that's kind of the red pill that I
really had was I just realized that the
things they were saying were true I
didn't like some of them I didn't think
some of them applied to me but you know
at the end of the day
if it doesn't apply Let it Fly
and
if we're at a point in society I'm
walking around Vegas I can't tell the
difference between wives and mothers
and hookers they dress the same nowadays
we kind of have to look in the mirror
and say well
this isn't a great direction that us as
a group are going
um
so I'm really just kind of tired of
hearing this like
the men are so evil and so wrong for
talking about the reputation that we
built because if a guy built a
reputation in a town nobody would
come at him if women started talking
about him like oh he's a reputation he's
a bad boy whatever stay away from that
guy
you know and I was thinking about this
if a man went around and robbed
everybody in a town
everyone will be mad but women every day
go around and rob their husbands of
their entire life savings
and if the men talk about it
their doomsdays
it's just funny you can't say anything
about women without being called a
misogynist without saying being said
that you hate women or you're just evil
and pessimistic when we got to be honest
we got to look at Trends throughout
history
and what women offer in return for men
building the safest Society ever
basically
um and the most prosperous Society ever
basically the funnest Society ever
basically the value we give back just is
lower really than it's ever been in
history
uh maybe for short periods of time but
you know I think when we look around
this is really the decline I tried to go
to church yesterday I was really trying
to go to church and
literally I'm like waiting for the
church to open and this crackhead sits
next to me
and there's some broken glass next to me
and he just starts saying that basically
he's like I'm knocking up
fight you with the glass something like
that and for me I'm like
I'm not going to sit here to find out he
told me he wouldn't I was like maybe I
could stay but
you know I'm not gonna sit here and find
out and this made me think wow
everywhere I go there's like these
homeless drug addicts in all the cities
this is in London I was just in Atlanta
this is in Vegas and
I really just think when you see the
quality of women decline like this it
shows and I'm not even saying I'm so
much better I'm amazing I'm just you
know as a group
when you see the quality of women
decline like this I think it shows that
civilization
like like we're falling off as a like as
a whole because it shows you have a
bunch of weak men that never tell us no
and don't expect anything in return you
have a bunch of entitled selfish women
as a group so you know
it's just my two cents but
maybe I'm crazy maybe you can just say
anything about women
and nobody will
nobody will push back call you a
doomsday or whatever but I don't know
it's like once you see this stuff guys
you just can't unsee it it's so crazy
it's so crazy I'll see women dressed
like hookers with a boyfriend that's
like what
what are we doing this is wild but you
know anyways guys like the video
subscribe to the channel
and where can I find I Twitter has
misled me they all told me that I could
find a piano
at the MGM Grand that I tried one other
hotel and I I don't know if I just can't
find it or what but I thought I could
play but anyways guys like the video bye